after she watched a few disturbing
videos of some shockingly well-fed
starving people celebrating the
beginning of the next phase of their
endless cycle of violence Patricia
Heaton who played Deborah in Everybody
Loves Raymond asked can an entire
country be filled with
psychopaths in theory yes one way to
fill an entire country with Psychopaths
would be to gather up all the
psychopaths in the world and put them in
their own country preferably somewhere
in Antarctica where the coldness of the
environment would complement the
coldness of their hearts just make sure
you figure out a way to protect all the
Penguins since there's a genetic
component to antisocial personality
disorder that's the personality disorder
Psychopaths have you could also breed
Psychopaths like dogs if you carried on
this project for a few Generations
you could end up with an entire country
filled with
Psychopaths but that's not what's
actually going on when you see large
numbers of people who all exhibit
Psychopathic Behavior what you're seeing
in these groups is something called
dissocial
psychopathy dissocial psychopaths are
people who exhibit the outward behaviors
associated with antisocial personality
disorder but may not actually have
antisocial social personality disorder
depending on how you're interpreting the
criteria dissocial Psychopaths have
learned to behave like Psychopaths by
being part of a culture or subculture
that encourages and rewards Psychopathic
behaviors think about someone who
doesn't have antisocial personality
disorder he's not a psychopath but he
joins a gang or the mafia or a terrorist
group where the behaviors that are
associated with antisocial personality
disorder are adaptive they help you
function in that group behaviors like
refusing to obey laws and Norms lying
and manipulation aggression and so on
are normally frowned upon or punished in
society but if these behaviors are
instead encouraged and rewarded in a
group members of the group will start
acting like someone with antisocial
personality disorder because that's how
you're supposed to act in that group
this might be easier to understand with
with an example from a movie consider
Jacob Harland from the film shot caller
yes it's the guy from Game of Thrones
Jacob Harland was a stock broker living
in California with his wife and his
young son super nice guy loved by
everyone family man but one night while
driving home with his wife and another
couple after having dinner Jacob crashes
into another car and someone dies Jacob
had some wine with dinner and he blows a
0.1 in the breathalyzer so they charge
him with driving under the influence and
vehicular manslaughter he takes a plea
deal for 16 months in prison but since
he has a manslaughter charge he gets
sent to Big Boy prison in the dorm on
his first night in prison he sees what
happens to someone who isn't protected
by a gang he realizes he has to join a
gang for protection so he joins the
Aryan Brotherhood but you have to work
in the Brotherhood they start making him
smuggle drugs to different parts of the
prison he eventually has to start
killing people and he doesn't have much
of a choice because if he doesn't do
what he's told they'll kill him too
Jacob gets caught on camera stabbing
another inmate in a race war so his 16
months turns into seven years by the
time he gets out he's already abandoned
his family he gets locked back up for
gun trafficking for the Brotherhood and
this time he gets life in prison when
the leader of the Brotherhood threatens
to kill Jacob's family for messing up
the gun deal Jacob brutally murders the
leader of the gang using a weapon he had
smuggled in up his butt then he takes
over the entire gang so by the end of
the film Jacob Harland has murdered
multiple people he's serving life in
prison he's covered in white supremacist
tattoos and he's the leader of a violent
gang he would seem like someone with
antisocial personality disorder if you
observed his behavior you would think
he's a
psychopath but there would be two
problems if you wanted to label him a
psychopath first one of the criteria of
antisocial personality disorder in the
diagnostic and statistical Manual of
mental disorders the DSM is displaying
conduct disorder earlier in life and
Jacob didn't he didn't have serious
behavioral problems until they were
adaptive because he joined a gang second
and I'll say this in technical terms and
then explain it one of the requirements
for a personality disorder diagnosis in
the DSM is that the impairments in a
person's functioning shouldn't be better
understood as normative for the person's
social cultural environment in other
words if the behaviors that are
associated with a personality disorder
are just normal in a particular culture
it's difficult to say that a person who
exhibits those behaviors is doing it
because of a personality disorder and
not because those behaviors are normal
in that culture if everyone in a culture
is taught to behave like a psychopath
how would you spot an actual psychopath
if everyone in a culture is taught to
behave like a narcissist how would you
spot an actual
narcissist so Jacob Harland would have
the same behaviors as a psychopath but
he wouldn't meet the criteria for a
diagnosis of antisocial personality
disorder putting all of this together
while it is possible in theory to have
an entire country filled with actual
Psychopaths people who have antisocial
personality disorder it would be much
easier to get a country filled with
dissocial Psychopaths people who don't
have antisocial personality disorder but
who have been conditioned by their
culture or subculture to behave like
Psychopaths can you think of any
cultures like
that hope this helps and for the sake of
full disclosure before a bunch of you
blurted out in the comments yes I've
been diagnosed with antisocial
personality disorder but I'm here to
help and sometimes it's good to have a
psycho on your side
[Music]